à l'image de berlin le reste de
l'allemagne poursuit son déconfinement
mais les pouvoirs publics tiennent à
rappeler que les infections pourraient
redémarrer si l'ensemble des mesures
restrictives sont supprimées de manière
précoce et d'un fond nous ne devons pas
devenir négligent maintenant surtout en
ce qui concerne le premier relâchement
il ne doit pas conduire maintenant à une
cascade d'autres mesures de
déconfinement supplémentaires qui se
traduirait alors par des contacts plus
étroits entre les personnes comme
auparavant
sinon il y aurait aussi plus
d'infections anglais près de treize
mille lits en soins intensifs sont
actuellement libres sur 32 milles au
total le pays affiche un taux de
létalité de plus de 3% en hausse mais
toujours inférieur à la plupart des
autres pays européens pour obtenir ces
résultats l'allemagne a augmenté très
tôt ses capacités de dépistage dans la
capitale les résidents du quartier de
nos cols auront prochainement accès à un
test au volant sans rendez vous une
initiative destinée à réduire le risque
d'infection dans des salles d'attentes
ou des établissements médicaux au delà
du suivi attentif des malades ce que
nous faisons déjà
nous voulons être prêts à faire des
prélèvements en masse c'est un élément
capital car nous voulons tester les gens
à grande échelle
particulièrement en vue de la
réouverture imminente des écoles terrain
de jeu jardins d'enfants et grands
centres commerciaux
autant d'endroits où les risques de
contamination sont bien plus élevés
qu'ailleurs mais la crise du coronavirus
n'a pas épargné l'économie allemande
depuis plusieurs semaines les commerces
de restauration sur place ont fermé à
cause des mesures de confinement
plusieurs comités de restaurateurs et
d'hôteliers berlinois demande de l'aide
au gouvernement
ce dont nous avons besoin ce sont des
mécanismes de sauvetage qui est vraiment
nos restaurateurs si nous n'avons pas de
parachute de secours dont deux ou trois
mois nous aurons 50 % de restaurateurs
en moins en allemagne
avec des centaines de milliers de tests
par semaine et le port du masque bientôt
obligatoire dans 10 des 16 états
régionaux l'allemagne mise sur un retour
progressif à la normale mais
rigoureusement encadré